a judge setting the veil for Nathan
chasing horse at three hundred thousand
dollars this is while prosecutors asked
for 2 million and alleged victim of
chasing [__] visibly devastated by the
judge's decision while some of his
supporters left the courtroom here
thanking the judge you cannot stress
enough from an individual discharged and
sexually assaulting multiple people that
they are inherently a danger to our
community prosecutors say Nathan chasing
horse is a Flight Risk he urged his
multiple wives to take suicide pills if
law enforcement showed up and he had a
plan for a shootout and police found
video of him sexually assaulting a child
who was unconscious along with evidence
that he's actively trying to groom
children this is after multiple women
have come forward to say chasing horse
targeted indigenous girls for decades to
then sexually assault them chasing
horses also believed to have resources
including devoted followers of his
alleged cult the circle if he leads our
jurisdiction the state submits that we
will not be able to get Justice for the
victims to come home Pro tem judge Craig
Newman setting that bail at 300 000
despite concerns even he acknowledges I
feel that there is a danger to the named
victims potentially as well as to others
as we first reported Tuesday chasing
horse is also facing charges in Canada
and the FBI is investigating reporting
in North Las Vegas Vanessa Murphy 8 News
Now